[Music]
hello everyone
so in the previous chapter on kinematics
after we had defined the engineering
string
[Music]
we had gone on to ask ourselves the
question that suppose we are sitting at
a particular point
and we know the the various components
of the strain tensor
at that point then uh
i'm given uh or are asked to find
the value of the engineering strain
along a particular direction we can very
well use
the formula that connects the
engineering strain to the
the strain tensor using the unit
unit the unit vector
we can we can definitely find that value
but we ask ourselves the question
that what is that direction along which
the engineering string
will be the highest so sitting at the
same point
the various directions around it so
which is that direction along which
will get the highest value of the
engineering stream and the way we
proceeded
was by discussing within the topic
of principle strains how to find that
out
and we and we did that by using a
lagrange multiplier
and by doing some kind of derivatives
now we could proceed in a similar
fashion uh
in in this chapter also because today we
are going to start discussing principle
strains
principle stresses so in the context of
principle stresses we
will get to the derivation of the of the
formula or whatever is required
uh a little bit later but first of all
let us try to uh
try to formulate in terms of a physical
question
like what we are trying to find out so
in the previous chapter
okay in the in the previous chapter in
kinematics we
we first defined the engineering strain
and then we
uh talked about the the maximization of
it
in this chapter what we had
what we have just discussed in the
previous part of the lecture
was the normal and the shear components
of fraction
and as mentioned near the end of the of
the last lecture
we are going to base our entire
discussion of principal stresses
on this normal component of the traction
in fact
what we are going to ask is
so let me refer to the slide
so if we refer back to
this thing
this particular formula you see that the
normal component of the traction
is connected to the stress tensor at a
particular point
through the two through this
n hat so the question we are asking in
this chapter
just like as we had asked in the
previous chapter on kinematics is that
what is the direction of n hat which is
going to maximize this value of
t n i repeat what is the
what is that direction of defined by
this
n hat such that the normal component of
the traction vector
gets maximized now your intuitive
feeling
may be that we can just proceed exactly
like
like earlier in fact the formula is so
very similar like
we don't even have to derive this and
it's true
i don't have to derive anything if we
were to proceed like that
but we don't want to proceed like that
rather we want to take a slightly
different approach
in order to get a better physical
insight of
whatever is happening with stresses and
fractions
so let us look at this picture
our question is what should be the
direction of n hat
such that the value of this tn
is maximized okay now forget about all
the formula
all the matrix representation everything
just think geometrically or very
physically
when is this tn going to be maximum
so suppose this t vector
where uh having a smaller
angle compared to what is shown here
suppose it was oriented like that
so the the the contribution
of the t vector to this tn would be a
little bit higher
so in the extreme limit that the t
vector
happens to be parallel to this n hat
happens to be okay so in general the
traction vector is never going to be
parallel to the n-hat
but in the very very special scenario
that the traction vector
is parallel to the n-hat
then we can say that the entire
pn that will capture the strength of
this
traction vector and there will be no
shear component of the traction left it
is in that situation it is for such a
plane
where the n n hat is such that the
traction vector is
is uh is parallel to the n hat it is
such a plane is referred to as the
principal plane and
the the stresses associated with it are
referred to as the principal stresses
okay so so instead of going by the root
of lagrange multiplier
and all the derivatives using the index
notation which we had done in the
previous chapter on kinematics
we are going to take a more geometrical
approach and we are going to say
that let us take a traction vector
such that uh it is parallel to the
n hat okay so this is the this is our
strategy now
so for principal stresses what we are
going to say is this
first of all we say that the
the n hat that is given by
n1 e1 hat
plus n2 e2 hat
plus n3 e3 hat
where e1 e2 and e3 are respectively
the the unit the unit vectors
along the three coordinate axis so just
referring to the previous figure
this the e1 is along this x1 the e2 is
along this one and e3 is along this one
the unit vectors along the three
coordinate axis
and n1 n2 and n3 they are the components
of the unit of this of this unit vector
n hat
now what we are saying is that the t
vector
should be parallel or
let me write it in words
for tn
to be maximum
we must have
t vector parallel to
n hat so that means
the t vector
will be a certain magnitude its
magnitude
multiplied by the n hat and what is that
magnitude
we understand that the entire magnitude
will be captured by
this tn so
this this is a very very important step
to write
so it will be like this okay the entire
magnitude of the t
vector is captured by the normal
component itself
because we know by definition that the
normal component
of the traction vector is the component
of the t vector
along the n hat but in this special
scenario
the t vector itself is parallel to the n
hat so the
t n is the whole magnitude of t vector
okay
[Music]
so that means if we expand it out a
little bit
it will be tn
n1
e1 hat plus tn
n2
[Music]
e2 hat plus
tn and 3
e3 hat all right
so this is one way of representing it
however
we could have also represented it in
another fashion
and that would be by using the cautious
formula
but before we do that what we'll do is
we will write
this entire equation which is a so this
equation
this equation which is basically a
vector equation in terms of
components so it's very easy but we'll
still do it for the sake of completeness
so it will be en n1
t2 will be dn into
and t3 will be equal to pn
m3 that's very easy
next what we are going to say is uh
we are going to use uh
so let me go to the next slide we are
going to use
this particular formula which is the
cautious formula
okay so that means
we have already written this earlier so
i'm not going to discuss this in too
much detail
[Music]
so i'm just writing down the the
[Music]
components
and of course i am utilizing all
throughout the symmetricity
of the stress tensor
[Music]
now you see
suppose i go back and
name these equations hash one
hash two and hash
three
and these as
[Music]
star 1 star 2
and star three
what i will do is i will
subtract all the three star equations
or rather the all the three hash hash
equations
from all the three star equations and
that will give me what
you see if i do star one
minus hash one here what will i get on
the left hand side i have
t1 here also i have t1 so this is going
to
give me 0 is equal to
sigma 1 1 minus tn
n1 plus
[Music]
sigma 1 2 n2 because you note
here i have no contribution from n2 and
n3 so
this is what i obtain
[Music]
next sigma 1
2 n 1
plus sigma 2 2 minus
t n n 2 because you note
that in hash 2 all that i have is a
coefficient sitting with this
n 2 so that contributes here and then
sigma 2 3 m3
and finally i have sigma 1 3
n1 plus sigma 2 3
and 2 sigma 33
as you can expect this is going to be
minus tn m3
all right now
uh usually when you are setting up
the uh the framework for finding the
principal stresses
what we say is that the very special
circumstance
or situation where the
the traction vector is parallel to the
n hat the normal component
which we have written here this normal
component
is usually given by the simple sigma
itself okay
this is just the simple sigma this tn
instead of this tn
we just write this as the sigma so if we
do that
then uh we can quickly
change our notation here
[Music]
to sigma sigma
and sigma and if we go back to this
thing also
we can change it to
sigma sigma sigma just a change of
notation
now the moment we have these things uh
you can understand that this can very
well be set up
in in a matrix form so
because each of these equations have the
n1 n2 and n3 which you note
are the scalar components
of the
unit vector of concern so we can set it
up like sigma 1 1 minus sigma
sigma 1 2 sigma 1 3
sigma 1 2 sigma 2 to minus sigma
sigma 2 3 sigma 1 3
sigma 2 3 sigma 3 3 minus sigma
this is written as a 3 by 3 matrix and
that is multiplied
with n 1 into
n3
and that is equal to the zero column
vector so we can write this as
zero zero 0 you understand
that the way that i have written it here
this is exactly equal
to what is present here in the form of
three separate equations
all right so uh this is basically the
framework that which you have come
across earlier
in your in the previous chapter of
kinematics and
this is the very familiar form of an
eigenvalue problem
so in order that
you have non-trivial solutions
for non-trivial solutions
[Music]
what we must have is that
the determinant of this matrix
the determinant of that matrix must be
equal to zero
all right so if we expand this out if we
actually carry out the
if we actually carry out the algebra of
finding this determinant
what we'll find is this can actually be
uh can actually be written
so i'm going to the next slide here it
can actually be written
in a very nice and clean form like this
sigma cube minus i1
sigma square plus i2
sigma
minus i3 is equal to 0
where
i 1 happens to be
just sigma 1 1 plus sigma 2 2
plus sigma 3 3
i2 is in a form
is a very nice symmetric form which can
be expressed in a very neat and clean
fashion like this
tonight
[Music]
and finally i3 is nothing but
the entire determinant of the original
stress tensor itself
okay so uh in case you're a little bit
uh
surprised by this i do please note that
if you just expand it out it will be
like sigma 1 1 sigma 2 2 minus sigma 1 2
square
plus sigma 2 2 sigma 3 3 minus sigma 2 3
square
plus sigma 3 3 sigma 1 1 minus sigma 1 3
square
because it comes out in that that form
it can be conveniently represented in a
more visually appealing form like this
similarly for the i3 okay
now what is so special about this uh or
is there anything special about this we
must ask ourselves this question because
it has come out in such a
neat and clean form is there something
special going on
actually yes uh because let's go
go back to the original figure from our
previous lecture
here you see uh we started our
discussion by
by specializing to the to a particular
plane
on which we are uh we we want our
n hat to be parallel to this um to this
traction vector
but other than that there is nothing
special about that plane meaning
that it is not that this n hat
necessarily has to be along the x 1 or x
2 or x 3
you must understand that now
[Music]
suppose suppose we uh
so so let me highlight this again what
i'm trying to achieve here
i'm trying to give you a special uh
special reason or motivation uh or
justification for
for these particular coefficients to
come out in the form
that they have okay because it is so
neat and clean
i want to highlight that there is indeed
something special going on
and that is why i want to to have this
discussion so
so we understand that in general the n
hat is not going to be along the x 1 x 2
x 3 that much is ok
however we are concerned about a single
point here
ok and we have drawn this plane like
this
okay and we are drawing the various
vectors uh
and we are writing out the various
components of the
of the vectors the the t1 the t2 t3
uh various things in fact the various
stress components the sigma 1 1 sigma 2
2 sigma 3 3 and
the rest of them sigma 1 2 sigma 2 3
sigma 3 1
but whenever we are writing out all
those components
please note that they are very very
specifically referred
to this particular choice of the
coordinate axis suppose instead of this
x 1 x 2 x 3
suppose we had chosen a different
orientation suppose we had taken some
kind of
x 1 dash x 2 dash and x 3 dash please
note that i am not changing the plane
itself the plane
the physical plane remains as it is
oriented okay
but what i am doing now is i am
considering a different
different orientation of my coordinate
axis my reference coordinate axis that
is completely under my wish
i can change it as i feel like so i'm
changing it
the moment i change it the original
vector
the original vectors the physical
meaning of those vectors they do not
change
however the mathematical representation
as far as the
the various scalar components the t1 t2
t3 the n1 and 2n3
they are going to change okay
now this is very very important
no matter what choice of the coordinate
axis
i choose here okay what orientation
whatever orientation of the coordinate
axis i may choose here
can it ever change the fact that
there will be a certain plane
on which the special thing about this
thing being parallel to this is going on
what i mean is if you are
choosing if if you have managed to find
out such a plane
where the traction vector the the actual
physical traction vector is parallel to
the
to the unit outward normal would it ever
depend
on the choice of your reference axis no
matter what axis you may
you may choose no matter what scalar
components they may be
represented by but the physical truth
that the traction vector
is parallel to the unit outward normal
to the plane
that fact is not going to change
okay this is an invariant
truth of nature that is not going to
change
the traction vector ref being parallel
to the unit outward normal to a certain
plane
that is a physical truth the
mathematical representation involving
the various components may change
with different choices of the coordinate
axis because that is just a mathematical
representation
but the physical truth remains invariant
and that is what is specially going on
here
let us come back to this thing this
final thing that we have found out
you see even though this i1 involves the
sigma 1 1 sigma 2
and sigma 3 3 and as i have told you
if i had chosen a different set of
coordinate axis
i would obtain different different
values of this sigma 1 1 sigma 2 and
sigma maybe they would be
called sigma 1 1 1 1 1 dash and sigma 2
2 dash and sigma 3 3 dash
the dash representing the different
choice of the coded axis similarly these
values the sigma 1 2 dash would come up
here the sigma 2 3 dash would come up
here and the sigma 1 3 dash should come
up here
but if you go back to this equation
okay these are the equations which are
telling you the values of this sigmas
what are these sigmas these sigmas are
actually
the tn the normal component of the
traction vector
and that is the physical truth as
regards its maximum value
and we have already said that that
physical truth cannot change
so we must and must conclude only one
thing
there is only one thing to conclude here
which is that
even if the individual values of this of
these various stress components may
change
but the way that they are combined
to form i1 that the way that they are
combined to form
i2 and the way that these are combined
to form the i3
that cannot change so no matter which
coordinate axis you choose
the i1 value is going to be in variant
the i2 value is going to be invariant
the i3 value is going to be in variant
that is
an extremely extremely important point
which is going to help you
all throughout your life as far as your
engineering practice is concerned
please understand the connection with
this mathematical
equation this is an equation it is a
cubic equation
it has it is going to have three roots
in general
those three roots will give you three
possible values of the
of the normal component of the traction
vector
now if you take different different axis
that is just a reference choice for you
that physical truth cannot change
and that is why the values of i1 and i2
and i3
cannot change okay it simply cannot
change the i1 i2 and i3
so even though these individual values
may change but the way that they are
combined
it is not going to change so it's
something like this suppose in one
coordinate axis your sigma 1 1 turns out
to be 1
sigma 2 2 turns out to be 2 and sigma 3
3 turns out to be 3
so all in all you have i 1 is equal to 6
okay with the correct units of course
maybe like in terms of mega pascals or
something like that but in another
coordinate axis
this sigma 1 1 value can have the value
2
the sigma 2 2 value can again have the
value 2 and maybe sigma 3 3 also has the
value of 2
but they'll always be like this that
their total sum
has to be equal to 6 okay again you
choose another one
maybe it comes out to be 1.5 it comes
out to be 3.5
uh so that is 5 and the sigma 3
3 has to be equal to 1 so that the total
is equal to 6.
in a similar fashion your sigma 1 2 can
have different different values
in different coordinate axes sigma 2 3
sigma 1 3 but
the particular way that they are
combined okay this is almost like magic
the way that they are combined
that is an invariant value given by this
i2
so that ingredients thing is actually
represented by the i2
here also this determinant value is is
is an invariant i3
so no matter which coordinate axis you
choose the roots are always going to be
the same meaning that the normal
component of the traction vector
is always going to be the same no matter
what what access you are referring to
and this is one of the most important
lessons perhaps the most important
lesson
on that you can that you can obtain from
this chapter
all right so we continue with our
discussion of principle stresses and how
we can build on that
uh to represent other things uh
so uh we'll stop here from uh for today
thank you very much